motivation was you know the common
operation maybe in this function I want
to make sure all the input lists have
the same length and so you effectively
end up saying you know apply same queue
onto a map of the list and they was one
of those sort of shortcut functions that
people write occasionally
let's not worry about it I think it's
not I think it's obscure for all the
reasons you said okay flattered
yes so finally discuss the game with DES
and yes his concerns were on the to
Hydra no he's not here but III know what
he conquered but he says so so the
problem is in this two arguments form
because we were we were thinking of
having a one argument form which is
basically the version of nothing for an
argument for our list of arguments and
then having a second argument specifying
the head in splices in - yup and that's
the case that can become problematic if
that head has hold attributes because
this one is agree I mean I think the
most important case is the list case
which is the same as nothing you know
nothing is something that nothing is
something that works in lists but not in
other things and I think it will be
perfectly good to be able to say um so
now the complaint is the past tense of
flattened there uni will discuss lining
me decide to
flood in somehow yeah to be flattered
right in languages other than English
that's probably some form that is an
immediate to be flattened look in this
case with nothing you're replacing you
know X with nothing for example mmm-hmm
you say I want to put in the list XY
which will be I mean you know I mean
this is kind of Auto flattening
the full full name I would think okay I
don't like that I don't like order
flattening I mean I think it's the
ponderous name and what are we gonna
call it um I mean we could talk about
names like splice but I think flatten is
a better name I mean I think flatness is
the name that we are traditionally using
I mean this goes along with flatten act
you know this is delete basically is the
analog delete delete is to nothing as
flatten that is to what
so delete see that's why we ended up
with flattened because flattened is like
the outcome but I agree that the outcome
hasn't happened yet so nothing is is to
put it sillily
is something that becomes nothing so to
speak am i making sense so this thing is
something that becomes just the elements
right I see I see a point that nothing
has the same to be done yeah right I
mean so this becomes the elements so
really what we want to represent is that
this is
let's write what we would write about
flattened okay we'd say flattened of
list of X 1 X 2 X 3 e 1 e 2 e 3
um represents what do we say for nothing
I see
you
well I mean basically is automatically
replaced by the sequence of elements e e
1 e 2
whenever it appears on a list
right that's what it really is which
makes the name flattened pretty obscure
given that that's the yes because we
then used a very flattening in that well
now of course obscurely enough okay so
sequence doesn't do this right I mean
the word which would often be used for
this is something like inline represent
it's a sequence of elements but I mean
this is the clear description of what it
actually does something like a sequence
list I don't want to use something with
sequence because what would sequence
list
I mean inlined is really obscure hmm now
wonder if there's something that can be
done that's analogous to nothing because
really what this is okay but let's right
some of the sentiments are elements only
that's horrible
well this is subversion this is like a
version of nothing for heads it's like
II had nothing okay no head I think
that's really obscure amusing but not
useful listless also unusable unlisted
how about
you
okay represents a sequence of elements
that that should be automatically
inserted into the list look the way it's
going to be done ma'am
a common thing will be something like a
X B X C slashed
X arrow something there right yeah so I
mean that looks quite beautiful
okay so
something like this
and we have the absurd function splice
from a milk we don't can we do document
splice hmm this is quite old
what splice splice Lee it's very old
it's version 1 I seems I think I've
never used this function sander is
asking does the function splice still
exist it appears to but it's been long
since deprecated so I have to say I
think we could reuse the splice term um
I cannot parse this name but um um and
JP o NJ pipe organ I got it
flattened is app flattened applies
sequence to flatten yes yes yes it is
it's it's some um I see the solder
suggesting NIT the problem is that
things are so freakin obscure if you see
them at a piece of code like this you
know NIT it's just like what the heck is
that
um I mean nothing is so nice compared to
that sequence isn't really usable
because well a because it means
something different in our language but
be because it's really what it's doing
is I look what about something like
unwrap or unwrapped
kind of obscure I mean I don't think
any better than the flattened case yeah
Sanders saying splice is the best option
but I don't think the promised splice
suggests it will actively do something
where is what this is doing is if it was
going to be something like that it would
be spliced which I don't really like
because it's kind of like it suggests
that this thing here should it be edie
or should it be ing of course nothing
ends in ing but for somewhat different
reasons
flattened flattening look the reason
that we thought about flattened I don't
think flattened is totally stupid out of
these because it is it is analogous to
flatten at gosh it isn't right because
flatten suggests a looking down in this
subtree exactly you need to go like two
levels up to do the flattened they are
right Oh
so I mean I don't think it is a
beautiful word but Auto splicing okay so
this coming back to the petals are there
any synonym of a headless yes that could
be used for here I mean this anything to
do with head heads is always somehow
utterly obscure um a headless ABC that
doesn't seem very convincing um I mean
people yeah in line is just not a term
that we use what is it really doing it's
taking these parts insert wouldn't do
this right one
we have inserted it insert is fine but
in this rule we are not inserting we are
replacing so yeah but also this peasant
right because insert
I mean insert just does you know I think
if we do this for example does that work
no it doesn't even work no it doesn't
have this decent notation yet you know
we probably should give it that notation
yeah well that does something completely
different completely utterly different
completely not what we okay well okay
well actually what about two suggestions
here splice in and interlace the problem
with these things I mean so interlaced
what interlaced is already a thing um
for some weird stuff with images but
that is actually in a sense a better
concept because it is in touch it is
interested it is yeah okay hold on there
is a great name out there for this
there's a name that's so obvious like
the word the name nothing took a while
to come up with as I recall um along the
same lines as interlaced may vary
interweave interwoven I think that gets
way too whimsical I mean I think I think
we're offered knitting needles at this
point well it's probably some weave
analogy to that right but what is it
that is happening this thing is kind of
exploding it's lustfulness upon you know
it's a pond arrival so to speak um you
know another totally weird word Auto
unlisting hopeless hopeless hopeless
hopeless um in some way of inline is
there any English
that is way too punny um it's kind of
nice but it's way too punny I mean it is
in a sense what's happening it's
unlisting but in a different sense of
unlisting d listing um I was thinking of
in least like in blame yeah I understand
I just don't get that I don't see how to
do it I don't see a word for that that
um I mean look the metaphor that we have
okay Auto flattening would that be even
the right term if it was called Auto
flattening would that say the right
thing no not really because it's not
flattening it's Auto yeah I mean look
the thing that is closest to being the
right thing is probably Auto splicing
it's a horrible thing it's a horrible
thing because of the fact that it's it
is okay this object is an auto splicing
thing not really what is this as a noun
what is this thing okay so sander is
suggesting a number of extremely dental
possibilities his first one is inlay a
subsequent one is implant um the problem
is these feel too heavy in layers will
in layers amusing I mean it's this just
looks
obscure though if you saw that in a
piece of code it's like what the heck is
that
jacketing it feels so technical I mean
it feels like that's some kind of you
know by Jackson or something and some
weird mathematical sense um and it feels
too much like there's a lot of action
going on injecting it's like you're
you're forcibly you know putting the
whatever it is into the um yeah it's
pointing out that that it's an operation
in the tree that replaced repeatedly
replaces a node with its children that
is correct that is what it does
um inject infuse Sandro's suggesting own
Amy
[Music]
okay any more ideas here right now it's
not exactly right but I was thinking
sort of along that line of stuff not
like stuff isn't and now stuffing
because then then we're gonna go tucky
go full Turkey right it's not inserting
or embedding necessarily it's a all
these names like like embedding and so
on the two fancier word this needs to be
something banal and simple like nothing
is either that or it has to say what
it's doing with incredible explicitness
like Auto something or other
um I mean really what it really is is
something that's not there
well actually it's worse than that it's
it's it's a it unpeeled
you know what it really is is it's
removing the list that's a way to think
about it though I got a weird background
noise here sounds actually a little bit
yeah
that is way too whimsical but the
concept is right pop in I don't know
what that's as in Mary or as in type of
flower or yeah I know it's the thing
that pops into place it it explodes on
contact um
I don't think in modern times we really
want something like exploding here um
tearing as in PA are it's too weird -
weird people I mean listen this is the
right concept yeah sander is suggesting
remove curly brackets
yeah well yep um I mean it is it's D
listed somehow unfurl Oh God I mean
unfortunately you know something like
that it just sounds way too general I
think we're on sort of the better track
here without lists unpeeled those kinds
of things because that's really what
it's doing right it's taking this thing
um this is a stew
one it's not comprehensible again
absolutely incomprehensible yeah peeling
the problem if it's a beer we say
peeling it's like the thing is peeling
like the paint is peeling off so to
speak it's not that it will you know
what it really wants to be this like
nothing represents nothing this is
representing this represents the
unpeeled version of ABC which can then
be spliced into there I mean there are
words but they're very obscure and
whimsical I mean things like xposed or
how about list removed ads - it's too
clunky something that explicitly
mentions least as they run they chose of
being more to the point yes not
suggesting that this is going to work
like a sequence anywhere right well this
is different from sequence in operation
well yeah because it is taking out that
list and stuffing as people have
mentioned the thing into those pieces
yeah I thought about unlisted with a
it's it's too weird it's just too weird
because unlisted is like you know the
company is being delisted unlisted
whatever it's an unlisted number you
know it's just the too many
conversations I think that unlisted
hasn't in the world at large um what's
it what's
synonym for without let's do there's
always sands
that's way too weird yeah we could go um
um I'm losing my mind what language is
song that's French right yeah French
then um okay so somebody is asking what
is the original problem the original
problem just so we're explaining it is
we want to function we have a function
called nothing called nothing which if
you replace an element of a list by
nothing then it the nothing just
disappears in the list what we are
trying to do is to have something where
if you replace this X by some wrapper of
some list that the elements of that list
that what this will turn into is simply
a DF b d c so it is as if x is being
replaced by the unwrapped version that
isn't the same as using sequence
no because sequence would be look to do
it with sequence a doing it with
sequence is is has all kinds of semantic
issues I hate sequence I've been trying
to kill sequence since it existed in SNP
in in 1980 it is the most semantically
horrifying thing in fact I bet you don't
even know what this is gonna do because
you don't know where the sequence is
gonna splice itself into the rule object
well it actually did the right thing in
this case but probably only because rule
specifically makes itself not some years
rule delay it if you had to rule delayed
our sequence hold but there are many
other functions like if for example
people complain that they cannot
propagate sequence objects through efz
when nothing propagates very nicely
through ease yeah the whole point is
that nothing is a very
control figures it only removes itself
from lists um actually someone here is
suggesting no list which is an obviously
interesting and simple suggestion not
really quite consistent with some of our
naming conventions but interesting I
mean that is definitely the trouble is
if you saw that a piece of code it's
just kind of what the heck is it
um decapitate yeah well actually
decapitated the capitated is more the
more the sentiment which is similar to
the without a head concept which we were
going for before all right what's the
best of what we have here um kind of
like inlay or maybe in splice but look I
see it is an inlay is your claim x is
the inlay well let's try and write the
text if it was in light okay my worry
with that is that we have overlay which
is so different what even is overlaying
oh yeah right CH for later different
it's the thing for images well but um
well okay so there's other weird
constructions like spliced in
the meaning it doesn't it does convey
the meaning you're actually into is an
interesting thing being suggested on the
livestream here that something um no
actually into isn't right because it's
this is spliced in how about flattened
in
I as I see the need of the inn so why is
London is the whole point is this thing
is a flattened in object look we can say
represents a sequence of elements that
are automatically well what we would say
is flattened into that automatically no
it's not really right all right listen I
I'm kind of thinking that's the least
horrible um thing someone is suggesting
on this live stream just make it a vote
no democracy doesn't work for things
like this that's my conclusion for the
last 40 years of designing software
we're treating this thing as an inert
sequence to call it that that is obscure
beyond belief because it requires a
knowledge of I mean that's kind of like
that that's that's one of those terms
that where you have to know the history
of the whole thing all right listen I
think flattened in is what we should go
ahead and implement it with we will come
back to this naming thing and hopefully
as we as we try and it's a little weird
it's a little weird and I think there is
a great name and we don't have it yet
further thought okay let's go on to the
next item
um oops output for
integer yes so this is a yes team coming
from Michael and he would like to have a
way of typesetting these inner with yeah
I know this is a kind of an ugly form
but the question is you know really what
we want is some kind of factored form
where I mean we're the only point is the
typesetting right where it's 2 2 to the
1 times y wow that doesn't produce a
time sign I'm surprised times okay but
but now in Michael's theory of the world
this thing would Auto evaluate yes I
mean in other words well clearly if I if
I actually enter that it'll evaluate so
is is his theory that this thing that
you know slash slash factored form would
produce this well okay is this what is
this idea well he wants something
meaningful typesetting but I guess once
it is one of these foreign things it
will be accepted in any other function
that takes a factor integer structure
and we have also unit dimensions which
is something we have also discussed some
times that it has basically the same
structure its Persian understand him so
what happens if I say unit dimensions
miles per hour yes
so factored form
also be able to represent this in a
nicer way
um are you saying who say that the head
should should or should not disappear in
the sense that matrix forms head does
not disappear
I think it's its head probably can't
disappear great okay so it will maintain
its form its look and will not evaluate
without getting rid of the head yeah
yeah right but I mean the fact is that
that by the way somebody is commenting
that we should have been using
we don't we haven't actually put in
synonyms have we we it's still just word
data of for example in lay comma
synonyms um
particularly
stay tuned come on they are great
decoration it's a filling terrific um
just
try the one or two other things that we
had splice well fill in could be used in
that setting yeah right yeah a lot of
these meanings I should have got great
tie or Wed also not very useful
okay onward um okay so the issue here
this this is something that would
operate somewhat like matrix form right
in the sense that it is doing that so
that percent remains that right yeah it
seems reasonable is it factored form or
factored form
I think factored form is probably I mean
really what this is what's another
example of this where one could use it I
mean one could say if one have mantissa
exponent of you know something for
another not great not what we wanted um
you know something like that now
Thank You thing need some and it's the
other factor though in fact the
polynomial factoring functions could
could use it in What's in what way I
mean they already have I guess yeah yeah
you know because it's symbolic I mean
the issue here is that because we can't
you know if we would have presented in
the case of polynomials because we're
not Auto expanding we can drive actors
as we present them the issue here is
that it would also expand and so we have
to present the factors in this way I
think factor form that just produces
this and and basically it's a very
simple creature
it just takes lists of pairs and in this
particular case it would say length unit
to the one time unit to the minus one
and the traditional form does this have
an interesting traditional form what is
that we don't have michael here do we no
we don't that looks truly awful um
though of course it can't know right i
mean the fact the traditional form of
the factored form could be something
perfectly nice um but what
present a quote slang fear it's usually
just with an L right L for the one T to
the minus one so that's probably what
the traditional of that should be what
is that thing anyway
what is length unit is it a symbol oh no
it's the string it's a string yeah
that's kind of grotesque why is it an
entity the the short answer is we built
the unit system before the entity system
existed but I'm not sure I mean I guess
there could be a physical dimension and
a domain I would think so I mean why
isn't this analogous directly analogous
I mean that's a length unit that's a
generic length unit just like meters is
a specific length unit in the making
sense it is itself an entity no it's not
an entity there this may also be
connected with the physical quantities
that we also like yeah like flux or
something okay I think we need Michael
and the rest of that team to actually
have a meaningful discussion about this
um do you know if this has an
interesting traditional form I don't
think it is it probably should have all
right can we look I think factored form
sounds good
but can we put a separate discussion on
the books for I'm talking about what we
do with length unit and so on okay I
admit that this because meters appears
essentially in a string inside the
quantity object it's hard to argue that
that should be a an entity there
I'm sure Michaels thought about this
okay should we move on mm-hmm make geo
elevation data closer to geo image is
that so that's the world not upside down
okay so this links to a suggestion of
yours of paddy in geo range etc to do
division later so thinking about that
and and because of recent work on on
extending your image so my point of view
is that we could consider that the
elevation data is an array of data which
is the image data of an image and then
everything that we can do to images we
can do to this erase yes okay so like
what like for example we have enjoyment
we have geo projection we have the
arrange and your Center and various
options that we don't yet have in the
elevation data but products would be
easier easy to reuse all that code I
mean for example to your projection is
an interesting option for geo elevation
data in this case for example it will
really affect the structure but what
happens if you say geo projection so
okay let's just to be clear what we're
talking about if we say Geographics
rearrange all geo projection arrow i
don't know what's lambert azimuthal or
something um then what we will have is a
world you know that's hardly the shape
of an image yes
so that's the question at the end that I
wanted to discuss with you what do we do
with these background points so images
in images in your image your image
doesn't have it yet but it's going to
have now a background option that you
can say read and then this appears right
yeah I understand but so let's walk
through a little bit okay so geo image
so if I were to do this same thing here
for geo image are you telling me that
geo image would produce the lambert
azimuthal wow it does that's pretty cool
how does that work
doing the definite you're doing
essentially the image geometric
transformation to make the thing that
projection is that correct yes
you
the same way we're doing it for the
background tiles for a map satiric
exactly does the North Pole actually I
guess the ice is just considered melted
there okay but that's nice there no
there's no discontinuity at the South
Pole or nothing like that how did you
achieve that well this is a little blue
circle there because they're the actual
thing comes from Mercator tiles
sometimes and then we interpolate the
colors a bit to imitate because we know
there is nothing in that little circle
well at the South Pole and and then and
at the North Pole as well maybe that's
talking about South though I know
there's an actual pole of the south yes
but if we go to our images in the
correct angle etc it's basically right
so what happens if I say I'm just gonna
look at this if I say South Pole very
nice why did that why did that actually
why did that not have the geographic
okay geographic object
okay geo position of South Pole
what is the geo position of the South
Pole that's that's going to be converted
into your position of minor 99-98
okay okay but so if I go okay the geo
position of the South Pole let's say I
say geo range arrow ten miles is this
gonna give complete garbage well it
depends on the projection because this
is yes I was like a bug to me well the
Diploma is that it's trying to get
market of tiles they are not and any can
not do anything there how far do I have
to go before I can get any it's five
degrees so how much is that what the
heck is that it is Mercator use you see
a projection goes to yes number two
meter
so geographies oh yeah it's not there
because this America tour tiles we don't
have them oh it doesn't go that far
exactly make it a telescope up to 35
degrees also what do we do beyond that
we just put some constant color Oh can't
we get surely somebody has photographed
the polls can't we get that that that's
kind of embarrassing the original tiles
who use for for satellite are Medicaid
or tiles so we don't have that
information
well for example the tiles will create
for street maps etc as we create
ourselves from our Sam we do go to the
polls okay so if I do this okay so
you're telling me if I were to do this
and I were to say instead of two um I
try with like your graphics here yes or
for example in your image try the second
argument relief map GOM
well what happened here so that this is
there aren't any streets there exactly
yes
but the train goes disappointing that
nobody's put the South Pole Station and
osm maybe somebody should do that
anybody want to send email to Steve
ghost and suggest that somebody does
that can we do that yes we will okay but
no case but if I go much closer into the
South Pole well maybe it's just not
visible if I go ten miles from the South
Pole or something here you're telling me
what the heck is that
it's just they did its cutting an image
in in the correct angle project
prediction and then projecting it try
try instead your background goes to a
relief map in here yes because then that
there is structure there we have
elevation data up to the polls last this
is totally weird it's still due to too
small yeah because what because the
weird these are basically big solution
o'clock term that they would decide that
aliens visited the South Pole its but
but I just wanted you to see some
structure what is all of that is that is
that
is that boundaries of tile boundaries or
something the projections into our
boundaries yes I think so it's
interesting so so if we do the same
thing just okay that's better if we were
to do the same thing here what is the
way geo position what happens if we do
this on the moon
are we getting using McCotter tiles on
the moon
well it's relief mat we do have data of
relief map so it's going to have been
something so is that right yes it's
rather embarrassing with three Wow well
it's kind of embarrassing but our own
planet isn't properly you know we don't
have good data but what happens if i if
i zoom in on the on the lunar pole yes
so if i hundred miles on the moon mean
yeah a long way exactly yeah but it's
still not embarrassing I mean that's I
understand that those aren't you know
it's slightly digital but those are
still not now what happens if I do this
for with a Mercator
what just happened there do you
understand that
for it ngo projection yes because
Geographics chooses the appropriate
projection while your image selects
Mercator thank you 400 I see Geographics
is allowed to choose the projection
exactly so if I said Geo image here and
then I don't get to have at your
background
exactly you so new that I'm in the
second argument I don't even know what
this possibly could be what is that
that's that's a big mess I mean that's
some serious reaction on the moon its
Mercator projection trying to do
something at the pole but the poles are
mapped to infinity in Mercator
projection so that the poles are really
terrible in Mercator projection right
right right right right right
so it's seeing but if I would have but
in fact we have the data these tiles are
not purely Mercator tiles is that a true
statement on earth exactly because these
are generated the relief blood from
elevation data now the problem is that
we first dude we first do they relief
blood in a cone rectangular and then
project that's why this looks pixelated
if we had the ability of having geo
projection in generation data itself it
will return the univision right so what
you're telling me is that the geo
elevation data is in lat/long bins
always next whereas the teal image is
not in that long bins it's in my cater
which is kind of screwy
it's in my cater my cater bins so to
speak yes but your image has your
projection option so it can change if
needed
while the elevation data cannot change I
understand what you're saying is so if I
look at you image of this right what
you're saying is that the background
pixels here are just white exactly right
so the question is what's the a load of
that in geo elevation data is it to say
that the way I think of the background
pixels have to be missing I mean the
background has to be missing but the
idea of the Bergeron option allows to
specify a color which is very nice big
you can still keep the full array of
data in the image fact and we want to do
the same thing alright so my suggestion
will be to create an option that allows
us to specify a value and then the user
has to say oh if I find this value it
means there was an a value of innovation
debt so it's kind of setting a floor
yeah Wow
I mean that seems kind of a hack it
seems like what we you know the main
issue here this is a hack because we
can't pack missings yes but even for
example for imagine the visualization we
do we still need to put something there
well but missing can render however we
choose to make it render but let me just
let me just zoom out for a second to the
whole issue here so the main issue is
geo elevation data is right now in equal
rectangular lat/long bins is that
correct yes and the question is should
you be able to get it in non lat/long
bins just as in the case of you know if
you say I want my image I want my field
and I mean that agriculturally in some
sense to be you know I don't know how
fields are actually drawn there probably
not I don't know if they're drawn and
that long bin so actually I know that
they are at some place it's never mind
that's a stupid analogy ok so so but but
my point is if you want to know this
region of like for example in the South
Pole case clearly ok the South Pole case
were we to have equal rectangular image
tiles then we would have a beautiful
South Pole right
because the pole is aligned in the
correct angular so it's always difficult
to convert it into a point even epsilon
away from the pole and we're still okay
right it's only the it's only there's a
there's a discontinuity at the pole
itself
yes but epsilon away we're still if we
had equal rectangular okay so what does
it do in the case of geo elevation data
what happens if I say geo elevation data
of the South Pole what does it say
and that would be geo position of minus
90 a zero mm-hmm I have no idea what the
elevation of the South Pole is okay well
that's good what does it do if it's plus
90 the North Pole
the ocean that's the Arctic Ocean hmm
that's a little weird by the way we
don't have any option to give the liam
you know what the actual ice surfaces
don't tell me it's changing I know that
[Music]
but the measurement like the radar
measurements from the shuttle must must
be the ice surface not I mean this is
bathymetric data taken voiced by some
you know submarine underneath the ice
mm-hmm which is really weird so what
this is saying is yeah I see so this is
why the relief plots here is showing up
at the northern end yeah okay is that is
there any I mean should we fix that in
some way it's I'm sorry I think we have
a committee there for the ocean so I
think my my question is if we wanted if
you wanted to know you know what the
actual solid surface of the earth was I
mean it's the only place on the earth if
I'm not mistaken well I don't know if
there's a frozen lake I guess you have
the same as here anybody has that data
the um okay that's a separate thing not
relevant to this okay but so there's
nothing wrong with you elevation data at
the poles okay how does that work again
I mean you just told me that there's
that it's in lat/long bins and this is a
discontinuity in the lat/long bins well
we need to make sure that all failures
and latitude 19 for all religions
coincide I see what you say okay fine so
I mean if I were to say 10 degrees here
it got these what well it should they
should coincide if the data we have
modified the data but
just just for my entertainment value if
I were to take this n let's just see
what it looks like I mean in let's say
in 5 degree increments or something and
goes from so where does it where should
it go 0 to 180 is that right - 180 to
1/8 it okay
can I do this more efficiently than the
way I'm doing it yes you can put the
elevation data or the Geo position of
the table and if we go in one go okay
well let's just see what this is looking
like so this is this is a little weird
if I might say so yes I think at some
point we have known that there's a you
see it's not a very large difference but
it it's it's how the data comes right
but so this is I see because probably
what happened is this data was not taken
right at the North Pole
[Music]
mr. at the South Pole I wonder whether
it also has this weirdness or whether
the South Pole I mean I've no idea what
the oops
it is always funny when people
say there's this discontinuity in the
coordinate systems at the north and
south pole and people say oh that's you
know who cares this is this is one of
them cares moments for that recently I
saw only if you're at the North or South
Pole yeah a long time I mean like that
if the Northwest Passage opens to
shipping they worry about it a lot how
close is it I forgot that from one of
our conference attendees at that time
was was admirer okay the other system
right yes um I recently saw a video of
somebody who claimed had found and a
motorway under the sea because it and
the point is that the data had
indecision in Google data they had a
discontinuity at the deadline but
longitude 180 from pole to pole and he
was convinced this was an alien robot or
something like that and the video has
millions of views great ok seriously do
we have any idea what's going on here
why why I said again I think I knew this
at some point it may be that the data we
have our pixels our Center pixels and so
we are computing the value or at the
pole calling the closest pixel value
center pixel so the data actually is a
bit of the polaroid okay so look there's
clearly some weird issue with polls
right
I I hate this idea by the way of having
a fake missing value to avoid unpacking
I think it's an incredible hack and I
think instead we should investigate
particularly with all the new work
that's been done on underflow and so on
the possibility of maintaining packing
even in look even when there's a missing
there who is involved in that issue is
that market people it would be mark and
Grover yes yes so we have had two
similar issues with errors for example
how do you market not just a missing but
in genetic error yeah well I know I
think what should happen is there should
be a way of setting in a packed system
there should be a way of setting a man
like thing yeah and then having some
kind of table of you know the nan of
position such-and-such corresponds to
such and such like a sparse array kind
of you know side table
mm-hmm that's what I think we should do
and I think um I mean I would raise that
point rather than adding a hack here but
look in terms of geo image geo range
seems like an obviously useful thing and
fairly uncontroversial
well true statement yes if we take this
new point of view of a now in the same
generality that we allow into your image
because um it uses the first argument in
a different way
so in your elevation data we put two
corners well in your image we we can
place anything and an entity
chill image you can have an arbitrary
entity so for example if I say Q image
of New York City for instance am I going
to get a Geo image of the whole of New
York City
[Music]
I think why is it so slow on earth is it
doing there we go
anybody know New York City well enough
to know that's Manhattan I know that is
this is this everything including
various boroughs and so on or is it
incorrect yeah it looks pretty complete
well it's but is it too big or is it
about the right size it's mostly right I
think you can use Geographics of the
polygons of New York City and we see a
polygon we are using okay I mean you've
got a little bit to the upper left that
you don't want but yeah but you can't
afford got for Carrere right it has to
be a square yeah so it looks about right
um penny you probably wouldn't mute
because you've got that girl right here
yeah it does look looks perfect right
it's using that polygon to find the
nearest enclosing square okay so I did
not really have not really internalized
that your image can deal with
projections and that then it is simply
using so you're saying it will have a
background option which is the visual
pixels to use outside of the region
defined by the projection right yes
because that's what all of their image
functions do yeah and it's the right
thing for this to do okay so the
question is is there any other data
function that can have I mean I could
that can have a data a function that
returns an array like geo elevation data
does what does it do when things are
missing
nothing they fail I think this has been
an issue for quantity array for example
because sometimes one values missing and
then quantity arrays unhappy that's no
good
so the this issue of the not having a
way of representing errors and packing
has is known and okay fine so we
probably need to deal with that but in
the in the short term by the way have we
even considered I hate to bring this up
but but random asteroids and things that
aren't spherical we we have the ability
of adding them to geo model and we have
for some of them we have data about the
radius as a function of a lot long is it
always all is it obvious so these things
are like homeomorphic to spheres or
something so you could give you can
parameterize them at lat/long yes
there's no the most we have is three
values for the three axis of animation I
see I see
but in principle the way to represent
you know a potato shaped object is still
is instead of in addition to giving play
to Phi Theta Phi uniquely to you know on
the earth Theta Phi do you know
determines are and then how do we
generate if you want another distance
from the center of the earth to a
particular lat/long we get that from the
yes from the curiosity later yes yes and
actually the elevation data has a second
argument which is specify the type of
elevation you want and one of them is
that one it gives you the distance from
the center of the earth okay fine I
think account there yet
right I mean the issue is that the
projections I'm sorry I this is probably
an irrelevant thing but if you have a
potato shaped object the lambert
azimuthal projection is perfectly
meaningful because it's simply a
transformation inside of ice by
well most projections are designed for
its spherical models and some of them
have formulas for ellipsoid on models
assuming an ellipsoid of revolution like
there isn't the case
I mean if you were to look if I want to
take damos or whatever it is and I want
to you know um and I want to show the
lambert azimuthal projection of it isn't
it the case that i simply have to map in
theta phi space the you know where i
draw
later equals such-and-such on my final
picture correct well if you do that you
would be first taking some sort of
projection first your popping out from
the center of the thing exactly and
projecting it out onto a sphere exactly
I see the projections you want some sort
of realistic map of the local area and
you would lose the eye area right so the
area is wrong so you take something if
it was very close to the center of the
sphere if there was a big depression in
the asteroid or whatever then by the
time its projected out to the sphere it
will be much bigger and its area will be
wrong okay I get it okay so what is the
point what what do we think we will use
geo elevation data in a non equal
rectangular projection for well because
for example somebody wants elevation
profile of a local area and it's quite
to the north where the equity stronger
projection distorts a lot
I see elevation profile so you say I
want to look at the you know the the
profile of the mountains in Greenland or
something great and if it isn't aligned
with the lines of latitude you claim
it's gonna be bizarrely distorted yes so
for example to take a map of inequity
angle a projection of a city which is
very known and and you will see that day
what should be rectangles and streets
aren't really really I mean there's
lovely places that I visited a couple of
years ago let's see does that have is
that far enough north it's like 78
degrees north or absolutely absolutely
it's this far enough north but you'll
see this phenomenon but but this is
going to be a Mercator projection so
should we now do a good rectangular the
projection goes to a rectangular and you
will see how much this map is distorted
sorry so they're going to do this for
water yes so do the same thing but now a
correct [ __ ] ejection goes to a correct
angle oh wow
you think so if we did a profile
generation data profile we would get an
hour shade while we want the upper shape
I see I see
but so most projections so Makita
an equal rectangular both map squares
two squares are not square I mean sorry
rectangles two rectangles is that true
yes but distorting in the process
allowed the shape no but in terms of
whether you end up with a pixel array or
a you know a proper rectangular array
those will both respect rectangularity
whereas something like what is the
property of a projection that causes it
to respect rectangularity reserving
what's that sealing the cone projection
well there is also the concept of
conformal projection which is
rectangularity in all directions yes but
that's more than requiring
rectangularity in the in the coordinate
directions
yes that's indigo so okay so over the
projections if I say geo projection data
how do I find out which ones are
cylindrical this right ceiling to go
okay so there's a
bunch of them that are cylindrical and
for these there is no problem in mapping
okay so the ICU is for ones other than
this what to do okay you're convincing
me that there's a reason I mean the Geo
elevation data okay the issue is geo
graphics with geo background goes to
relief map gives the pixelized version
of geo elevation data with geo
projection error whatever correct yes it
does it by first bring in the
equirectangular data and then construct
your image and projecting it right so
what we will be able to do with
generation data with a projection is
bringing the data already with that's
projection no no I get it I get it but
I'm trying to understand for the analogy
in that case the background is
determined like it is in images just by
a background option and will otherwise
be kind of white or something right
yes except in the case of Geographics
the question of let me see so the but
the issue that you're trying to figure
out is the analogy between geo elevation
data when it's out of when the
projection is undefined well in
particular because geo elevation data
returns a rectangular array there will
be elements of that rectangular array
that corresponds to things which are not
defined parts of the projection right
yes exactly
and what do you want to do you want you
want to just have a I mean what we could
do as a kind of hack I have to say is to
actually have a background option maybe
this is what you were proposing is to
have a background option for geo
elevation data which for the time being
you could just set to something like
zero then perhaps what we could do is to
set it to automatic and in the in the
future what we can actually support
missing we could we could have it turn
into missing instead right yes so I was
thinking that because back row always
goes to a color or something in
graphical rather than quantity we will
do quite a new name like we have missing
style also to interpret what is a style
that is what are you proposing that
something like missing value or don't we
have something I mean by the way does
this work in a different projection or
is this just dynamic graphics work in
another projection does dynamic graphics
only working and only Mercator and Niger
externally because those are the two
ones for which we have the tiles
pre-processed so dynamic graphics we
don't want to lose time projecting
so you can't really what is it just do
by default this is this is this is
Mercator so by default is always
Mercator at every scale if you do
dynamic Geographic your projection goes
to a correct angular you will see how
distorted this looks so this is the
reality the actual collective because
medicator is conformal I see but so if
you say if I do this an equal
rectangular then it will be completely
wrong yes I was a clever old locator to
actually get a conformal projection back
when he did maybe it was obvious at the
time you could do that but um why can't
I resize this help II yes um this is
bread would have seen that sometimes its
front anything oh okay but you're saying
that this I see that's bizarrely
misshapen so we could in principle
generate tiles we could pre-generated
for some other projection but we have
not done so it's nobody's mr. care is
that a fair statement
yes it's very expensive to keep a full
set because when we go to deeper zooms
yeah I understand no aliens for that are
we allowing I mean we're dynamically
generating this one we go to zoom level
14 or something exactly we have until
June 13 we generated and then we
generate them but already so 13 is a lot
yeah I understand him and also I suspect
nobody cares right because in general
for a single image in Geographics we can
projecting real time right okay look I
don't know what to do with this
background option I I would just put it
in as a ordinary background option for
the time being I mean this thing is a
hack and let's just we've had some
interesting comments on the live stream
let's take a look at those before we
have to wrap up here Phillips it will be
very nice if Geographics at the same
sort of click tools that images volumes
etc have yes it would be wouldn't it yes
well it has some so if you click the
image and then period what I click the
image and then I place a period exactly
my god I had no idea you move the cursor
and you get that how would anybody ever
figure out that that's there I said they
didn't know that was the one how do I
copy those those numbers you click to
get a position and then I think you have
to click outside and do control see this
is the coordinate tools this is the
generic coordinate tools of graphics
that why doesn't it come up I don't a
stamp why doesn't it come up with a cuz
graphics oh oh okay so we don't have the
attached itself or graphics here unlike
if I did how do I get a random image
well if I say random image whatever um
okay but here I will get explicit tools
and then I have the explicit coordinate
tool right so why aren't we at least
putting that attach thing if we have
that working why aren't we at least
putting that as an attached cell element
even if there aren't other things like
clapping and so on which we don't does
not so obvious we need to support well
fix follows graphics but I'm asking the
question even for graphics which is kind
of I haven't thought of performing just
graphics support the same thing my gosh
we probably had this for 20 years and I
didn't know it
yeah well arguably the way we should do
that and this is a thing who's appearing
here is it Sushma
I think that's the thing for the user
assistance meeting and what I'm
suggesting is that we at least give that
piece of the attach cell right
support it why not just even if we you
know there are more elaborate parts they
attach cell that we could give that's at
least some Discovery interface for that
feature which otherwise has absolutely
no Discovery interface I mean ultimately
we probably want the full drawing tools
and I don't quite know I mean that
that's been this project for a while to
slim down the drawing tools so that we
can actually have them as a - sell on
graphics okay that long rollin pixel
coordinates yes getting distances in
here yeah well that's not so simple is
it I mean in other words if you if you
draw if you have two points here knowing
their distance I mean getting out those
two points in doing geo geo distance is
a reasonable thing to do but they leave
the line the chiid s ik on here is
certainly not a straight line um great
yes the straight lines in matadora
so-called looks in terms from where so
flip also Watts elevation interactively
which probably we could do yes that we
could do but that's an interesting idea
yeah let's see
measurements annotation tools for look
we want to do this for general I mean
we've had drawing tools for a long time
but it's just not been you know first
they've never I don't know I always find
them too hard to use even though we've
definitely simplified them over the
years um and I also think yeah I mean
look there's no good reason and this is
something else for the user assistance
meeting there's no good reason that we
shouldn't have a tab down here along
with the coordinate tool that will allow
one to at least in fact that is the
coordinate tool isn't it yes that is the
coordinate tool so what we should be
doing is at least having some attached
tabs here that number one bring up the
coordinate tool and number two actually
bring up the drawing tools palettes
why not so even if you know even the
existing drawing tools palette but what
we really want is a better designed in
line drawing tools palette that goes
underneath um yes zoom and pan for
graphics we're aware of that issue this
is measurement
um okay graphics might support the yes
okay so let's see was there anything
else here on the we might just get the
next one is very simple so I think we
might just do it but but this this
particular thing with them okay so the
the action items from here are let's
implement geo range and so on for geo
elevation data that seems harmless
enough don't we have some other things
like that like geo gravity data geo
gravity model data doesn't it bring back
the same kind of thing yes eventually
yes they also take her tongue region
they could also be generalized in the
same way right I mean it's hardly the
most urgent thing but it seems like a a
desirable thing and probably the same
code block but okay so that's first
thing and then with a background option
which is a hack and we should consider
experimental for now that allows one to
fill in what you're right it isn't the
right name I mean it's it's um maybe
it's background value or something what
do we what is the analogous thing in
sparse array it doesn't have an option
name does it it's just an argument
exactly it's an argument and we call it
debugger on Bernie background value well
maybe we should just call it background
value then all right fair enough
okay let's consider it expect look we
can put it as an option and tag it as
experimental background value for G
relation data but now the question let's
see okay so the other issue was the
horrors of the North and South Pole
weird
so there I have an idea which is that
recently I have extended their
Geographic so that it's able to interact
with a Geo server in which the tiles are
in a polar projection which is the right
thing to do here so we have something
circular for the poles and then we we
take the tiles from there nicely okay
that's going to solve this problem okay
great so then the North and South Pole
will be perfect
and we have the imagery right we have
satellite imagery from that we don't cuz
we don't because typically because all
these maps that you see in the Internet
are owned by Medicaid or maps they don't
care about provider for that I bet they
have it unless their satellites don't
don't orbit now I mean I don't know
whether the their elio satellites do
they okay
so let's tell mechanics question does it
does it yeah they must not because I
remember like the iridium phone coverage
doesn't include the Antarctica for
instance or didn't until recently
include the Antarctic so I'm guessing
that that you can have is that right
that you can have an Elio satellite that
never that there's not a Ghatak relative
to the points on the earth I've
certainly seen those plots when they
don't I I'm a little confused but maybe
maybe they simply have not had
satellites that I I'm sure they have
those that data it's less fair enough
I mean we only have to get it once I
don't think we we're not gonna let need
to replace the South Pole tile very
quickly okay super quickly here
completely different topic numerator
denominator that seems like a no-brainer
and it will return a list so it will
simply be a list of the numerator and
the denominator like like we have a
quotient mod for example the quotient
remainder yes uhm yes or we find seem
sensible Danny do you have any objection
to that do you think it's stupid for
some reason okay all right we should
wrap it up thanks a lot guys thanks to
everybody on the livestream thank you
all for your suggestions and hopefully
flattened did we come up with flattened
in yes I think there was where we ended
up maybe we'll come up with something
more brilliant for that